PLANE, WHO KNOWS.
>> Sean: I'LL LET YOU
DETERMINE THAT IN THE MORNING.
BRIAN, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," A LOT
COMING UP TODAY, ROBERT WILL
JOIN US MORE ON THE PREDAWN
RAIDS AND IN THIS CASE IN HIS
HOME WITH FAKE NEW CNN CAMERAS,
HOW DID THEY GET TIPPED OFF?
THE LATEST DETAILS FROM
AMERICA'S PARTISAN TWO-TIERED
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
♪ ♪
CANNOT WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT BREAKING RIGHT NOW ONE
INDIVIDUAL WITH ACCESS TO THE
FBI'S SEARCH WARRANT USED AT
MAR-A-LAGO IS REVEALING NEW
DETAILS ABOUT THE DOCUMENT.
TONIGHT WE CAN EXCLUSIVELY
REPORT THAT THE WARRANT
IDENTIFIED TWO VERY VAGUE
CATEGORIES OF INTEREST.
ONE DOCUMENT SAID SHOULD OR
COULD BE IN THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND TWO ANYTHING ELSE
THAT MAY BE MARKED CLASSIFIED.
MR. GARLAND, LET'S SEE THE
AFFIDAVIT THAT YOU PREVENTED TO
THE TRUMP HAYDEN, OBAMA LEVIN,
JEFFREY EPSTEIN FRIENDS TO
FENDER MAGISTRATES BECAUSE THE
LIST OF WHAT THEY TOOK WAS KIND
OF ALSO VAGUE AND MEANINGLESS.
THE AFFIDAVITS AND WHAT YOU DID
TO GET THE WARRANT, YOU TOOK
RESPONSIBILITY AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT.
I SAID ON DAY ONE THAT THIS WAS
BIG FISHING EXPEDITION AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS ALL THE PRETEXT
AND THEY WERE LOOKING FOR ANY
AND ALL DOCUMENTS OF MAR-A-LAGO.
IT'S OFFICIAL, WE ARE NOW FULLY
IMMERSED IN YET ANOTHER
ANTI-TRUMP WITCH HUNT.
YOU SHOW ME THE MAN, WILL FIND
THE CRIME, AND NOW YOU CAN
ACCEPT THEY NEVER SEEM TO FIND
THE CRIME IN THE FACE OF
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE ONE DOESN'T
EXIST.
BY THE WAY, WHAT THEY TOOK WAS
MEANINGLESS SEEMINGLY WHAT WE
KNOW NOW AND AT THE SAME TIME
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON HUNTER,
THEY'RE ENJOYING A LAVISH
VACATION AND AN EXCLUSIVE ISLAND
IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
YESTERDAY THE FATHER-SON DUO
WERE ALL SMILES AND YOU LOOK
HUNTER BOARDING AIR FORCE ONE,
NOT A SINGLE CARE IN THE WORLD.
NO WORRIES ABOUT THE PREDAWN
RATE AT HIS HOUSE.
DESPITE PICTURES, VIDEOS,
EMAILS, TEXTS, EYEWITNESS
ACCOUNTS AND OTHER EVIDENCE
DETAILING A VARIETY OF SERIOUS
CRIMES RANGING FROM
SEX TRAFFICKING, DRUG USE,
ILLEGAL GUN POSSESSION, MONEY
LAUNDERING, TAX FRAUD,
VIOLATIONS, HUNTER BIDEN HAS
NEVER BEEN THE SUBJECT OF AN FBI
RAID AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE
INFORMATION THAT IMPLICATES HIS
COGNITIVE MESS OF A FATHER JOE
AS A LIAR LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NEVER ONCE TALKED TO MY SON
ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
WE KNOW IT'S COMPLETELY FALSE
AND NOT TRUE, AT LEAST 14 AND AS
MANY AS 17 INSTANCES, WE'VE GOT
PICTURES OF HUNTER AND HIS
FOREIGN BUSINESS PARTNERS WITH
JOE BIDEN.
IF IT WOULD MEAN THAT THE BIDEN
FAMILY AND PRESIDENCY IN
PARTICULAR, OUR PRESIDENT COULD
BE COMPROMISED BY RUSSIA, CHINA,
UKRAINE, OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
WERE PAYING HIS SON WITH NO
EXPERIENCE A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
IT EXPLAINED JOE'S PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT TO COUNTRIES LIKE
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
BUT BIDEN'S VACATIONS NOT GOING
TO BE INTERRUPTED WITH ANY
SEARCH WARRANTS.
NOT CLEAR HUNTER OR JOE WILL
EVER BE CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
THEY'LL GET AWAY WITH IT LIKE
THE CLINTONS AND LIKE EVERY
OTHER DEEP STATE ACTOR.
REMEMBER ALL THOSE NAMES?
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LYING ON A
PFIZER APPLICATION?
WE GET THE MESSAGE AND IN
TODAY'S AMERICA IF YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT, SMOKE CRACK ON CAMERA,
RECORD YOURSELF WITH FOREIGN,
SKIP OUT AND PAYING YOUR TAXES,
EVEN SELL YOUR COUNTRY TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER AND YOU'LL GET
AWAY WITH ALL OF IT.
IF YOU'RE ABOVE LAW.
KICKBACK, TAKE TONS OF MONEY AND
THANKS TO YOUR VICE PRESIDENT
FATHER AND GET DADDY THE VP TO
WITHHOLD A BILLION TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AGAINST SOME UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR FIRED FOR
INVESTIGATING THE MILLIONS THAT
YOU WERE PAID WITH BECAUSE YOU
HAD NO EXPERIENCE.
THAT'S A REASON TO GET PAID THE
MILLIONS.
BUT IF YOUR DONALD TRUMP AND YOU
COMPLY WITH THE BUREAUCRATS AT
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES AS WE HAVE
LETTERS FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES IN FEBRUARY SHOWED AS
WE KNOW THEY MET ON JUNE 3RD,
YOU STILL HAVE 40 WELL ARMED FBI
AGENTS GUNS DRAWN BANGING ON
YOUR FRONT DOOR UNANNOUNCED
BLOWING OPEN YOUR BRAND-NEW
SAFE.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA MOB THIS
WASN'T A RAID, THIS IS THE
PROBLEM WITH CONSERVATIVES.
YOU THOUGHT THAT WAS A RAID!
THIS IS ONLY A ROUTINE
GOVERNMENT APPROVED A VISIT FROM
THE FEDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TALKING ABOUT A RAID AND A
BREAK-IN, THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO
ADOPT THE TERM RAID.
THAT WAS AN INTENTIONAL USE OF A
WORD AND WE HAVEN'T DONE IT ALL
NIGHT, BUT I'M GOING TO SAY AN
IMPORTANT NOTE FOR OUR AUDIENCE.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AT MAR-A-LAGO A RAID.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOESN'T EVEN USE
THE TERM RAID.
>> THE ONLY REASON TO HAVE A
SEARCH LIKE THIS AND LET'S BE
POLITE AND COLLECT A SEARCH AND
NOT A RAID, PERIOD >> OFFICIALS
I'M TALKING TO ARE PUSHING BACK
ON THAT.
>> WHAT WE KNOW WHAT PLAYED OUT
ON MONDAY THAT IT WAS NOT THE
SORT OF THING YOU WOULD CALL A
RAID WHERE THE FBI GOES IN GUNS
BLAZING KNOCKING ON DOORS AND
YELLING.
IT'S BECAUSE THIS IS NOT AN
UNAUTHORIZED ERRATA, IT WAS A
SEARCH CONDUCTED WITH AN
AUTHORIZED WARRANT.
>> SEARCH OF THE PROPERTY WAS
NOT A RAID.
>> Sean: IT WAS A RAID, THIS
IS THE SAME MEDIA THAT SPREAD
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON'S RUSSIAN
DOSSIER IN THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
LIED AND SAID HUNTER'S LAPTOP,
THAT'S RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
AND THE MEDIA THAT LIES AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN AND THEY
DON'T STOP.
IT WASN'T REALLY ERRATA, REALLY?
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
COMEDY AND ADMINISTRATION CARE
SO DEEPLY ABOUT EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
I GUESS HUNTER AND JOE ARE GOING
TO EXPECT A VISIT IN THE EARLY
MORNING HOURS IN SOUTH CAROLINA
THIS WEEKEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ADHERENCE TO THE RULE OF LAW
IS THE BEDROCK PRINCIPLE OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
UPHOLDING THE RULE OF LAW MEANS
APPLYING THE LAW EVENLY WITHOUT
FEAR OR FAVOR.
UNDER MY WATCH, THAT IS
PRECISELY WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING.
ALL AMERICANS ARE ENTITLED TO BE
EVENHANDED APPLICATION OF THE
LAW, DUE PROCESS OF THE LAW, AND
TO THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
>> Sean: YOU'VE HAD HUNTER'S
LAPTOP FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS.
ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN WORDS
AND I THINK YOU'RE A LYING
HYPOCRITE.
OBAMA TOOK 30 MILLION PAGES OF
SENSITIVE POTENTIALLY CLASSIFIED
PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL TO CHICAGO
AND NOT ONE PAGE HAS EVER BEEN
RETURNED.
IF WHERE IS THE RAID ON OBAMA'S
HOUSE?
BILL CLINTON TOOK TONS OF ITEMS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IN ONE OF
THE TOP AIDES TRIED TO STEAL
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL FROM THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
SHOVED IT DOWN HIS PANTS AND
INTO HIS SOCKS.
IF WHERE'S THE RAID ON BILL
CLINTON'S HOUSE?
HIS WIFE HILLARY AS YOU KNOW
STORIED THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF GOVERNMENT EMAILS AND
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ON PRIVATE
SERVERS THAT WERE HACKED BY
OUTSIDE FORCES.
IF WHERE'S THE RAID ON HER
HOUSE?
APPARENTLY CHARGING HILLARY WITH
A CRIME WAS UNTHINKABLE
ACCORDING TO JIM COMEY THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
GOOD OLD JIM, SUPERIOR JIM, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MATTER, UNUSUAL TRANSPARENCIES
IN ORDER.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
STATUTES REGARDING THE HANDLING
OF EVIDENCE, NO REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD TAKE SUCH A A
CASE.
>> Sean: NO REASON --
REASONABLE PROSECUTOR.
UNLIKE HILLARY CLINTON WHO TRIED
TO DESTROY EVIDENCE,
DONALD TRUMP WAS COMPLYING WITH
FEDERAL OFFICIALS PRIOR TO THE
RAID AND HEAR WHAT HE HANDED
OVER MULTIPLE BOXES AS MANY AS
15.
THE FBI AND DOJ WERE AT
MAR-A-LAGO, THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES NOTED HIS COOPERATION
AND THE STATEMENT BACK IN
FEBRUARY AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT MET WITH THE FEDERAL
OFFICIALS FROM THE DOJ AND OTHER
AGENCIES IN JUNE.
SHOW HIM THE REST OF THE
DOCUMENTS AND ASKED HIM TO PUT A
PADLOCK ON THE DOOR SECURING THE
DOCUMENTS AT THEIR REQUEST AND
HE ALSO SAID COME BACK FOR
WHATEVER YOU NEED ANY TIME YOU
NEED TO.
BECAUSE HIS LAST NAME IS
DONALD TRUMP, NOT BIDEN, OBAMA,
CLINTON, HUNTER, IT WASN'T
ENOUGH.
THE FBI WHEN JUDGE SHOPPING, A
TRAUMA HATER ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
OBAMA LOVING PERSON TO
RUBBER-STAMP THEIR WARRANT AND
NOW ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES.
IF TURNING THE SECURITY CAMERAS
AT THE RESIDENCE OFF,
APPARENTLY THE CAMERAS KEPT
ROLLING.
THOSE WHO SEE THE FOOTAGE TELL
US THAT THE FBI DID NOT ACT IN
GOOD FAITH AND APPARENTLY AGENTS
WENT ROOM TO ROOM AND MANY HAD
GUNS DRAWN SCOURING EVERYTHING
AND ANYTHING IN SIGHT AND THEY
EVEN SEARCHED ROOMS NOT LISTED
ON THE WARRANT.
WHY WERE THEY GOING THROUGH
MELANIA'S POCKETS OF HER
WARDROBE?
MAKE NO MISTAKE, IF AND WHEN WE
GET THIS FOOTAGE, WE WILL SHOW
IT TO YOU IN FULL AND LET YOU
DECIDE.
IF THE FBI DOESN'T WANT ANYBODY
TO SEE IT AND THEY WANT ALL THE
COPIES FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO SEIZE THE
REPORTING'S AND COVER THEIR
TRACKS.
MERRICK GARLAND PROVIDED A FEW
DETAILS ABOUT THE SEARCH TAKING
NO QUESTIONS THEN HE SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN, BUT HE VEHEMENTLY
DEFENDED THE DOJ AND FBI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET ME ADDRESS RECENT
UNFOUNDED ATTACKS ON THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AGENTS AND
PROSECUTORS.
I WILL NOT STAND BY SILENTLY
WHEN THEIR INTEGRITY IS UNFAIRLY
ATTACKED.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE FBI AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ARE
DEDICATED, PATRIOTIC PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
EVERY DAY THEY PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM VIOLENT
CRIME, TERRORISM, OTHER THREATS
TO THEIR SAFETY WHILE
SAFEGUARDING OUR CIVIL RIGHTS.
THEY DO SO AT GREAT PERSONAL
SACRIFICE AND RISK TO
THEMSELVES.
I AM HONORED TO WORK ALONGSIDE
THEM.
>> Sean: I AGREE, 95% OF FBI
AGENTS ARE GOOD, HONEST,
HARDWORKING MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES.
I AGREE ALL OFFICERS DESERVE TO
BE SAFE AND PROTECTED, BAD
APPLES NEED TO BE FIRED AND/OR
INDICTED.
THERE IS NEVER ANY REASON FOR
ANY VIOLENCE AGAINST ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES, CAN NEVER BE
TOLERATED AS WE SAID REPEATEDLY
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020 I DON'T
REMEMBER ANY DEMOCRATS DOING
THAT.
THEY WERE EITHER SILENT OR
COMPLICIT.
GIVING OUT BAIL FUND ADDRESSES
AND ET CETERA.
MERRICK GARLAND, LET ME GIVE YOU
SOME REASONS WHY NO ONE TRUSTS
YOUR DEPARTMENT OR THE FBI WHEN
IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU ARE FBI, DOJ ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED FISA WARRANTS AND THREE
SEPARATE RENEWALS TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, TRANSITION TEAM,
AND TRUMP AS PRESIDENT.
YOU USED HIS OPPONENT
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER AS
EVIDENCE AND LIED TO A FISA
COURT JUDGE THAT SAID THAT WAS
VERIFIED AND IS UNVERIFIABLE.
DOJ OFFICIAL WARNS THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS GARBAGE BACK IN
AUGUST OF 2016.
YOU SAID IT WAS UNSOURCED,
UNVERIFIABLE, RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION PUT TOGETHER BY
AN EX-FOREIGN SPY AT THE REQUEST
OF THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
IF YOU WERE WARNED AHEAD OF
TIME.
THE EX-FOREIGN SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE NOTED UNDER
OATH THE MATERIAL OF THE DOSSIER
WAS UNVERIFIABLE BUT THE FBI AND
DOJ DIDN'T CARE AND NONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WERE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY NEXT WENT ON A TWO YEAR
PARTISAN WITCH HUNT LED BY
DEVOUT DEMOCRAT ANDREW WEISSMANN
AND STAFF WITH CLINTON DAUGHTERS
COME I REMEMBER HOW ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE, HE MADE NO
INSTITUTIONAL CHANGES, NO
REFORMS, AND THIS IS WHERE WE
ARE TODAY.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE DON'T TRUST
THE ONE GREAT LAW INSTITUTION
AND THAT'S THE FBI.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BY THE
WAY JUST LABELED CONCERNED
PARENTS SPEAKING OUT AT SCHOOL
BOARD IN EXCESS POTENTIAL
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS THAT NEED TO
BE INVESTIGATED AT REQUEST OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE SEEMINGLY ENDURED THE
DOESN'T OF ATTACKS ON PRO-LIFE
PREGNANCY CENTERS.
THE PROSECUTE VIOLENT FAR LEFT
RIOTERS WHO ATTACKED FEDERAL
BUILDINGS IN THE SUMMER OF 2020.
THE COURTHOUSE IN PORTLAND,
DOZENS INJURED AND AMERICANS
DEAD.
NOTHING TO STOP THE DOXXING AND
HARASSMENT OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A
LAW AGAINST THAT PROHIBITING
THAT.
THEY BARELY YELLED WHEN
CHUCK SCHUMER THREATENS THE SAME
JUSTICES BY NAME ON THE STEPS OF
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT.
THEY COULDN'T CARE LESS WHEN
KAMALA HARRIS PROMOTED THE BAIL
FUND TO GET RIOTERS OUT OF JAIL
AND TOLD THEM NOT TO STOP
RIOTING.
TAKE NOTES, NOT GOING TO STOP
AND THEY WON'T STOP AND THEY
WERE SHOULDN'T STOP AND WE
SHOULDN'T STOP.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE AT ALL
THAT THE DISGUSTING FRANKLY
BIDEN FAMILY SOLD ACCESS TO THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, CHINA, RUSSIA,
UKRAINE, KAZAKHSTAN.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND, YOU'VE
HAD